so wenn ihr einfach sterben wollte
meinen mensch beim backen richtig
bisschen hallo meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen mal wieder zu einer
neuen mod vorstellung und zwar von der
trailer mix modifikation und was er
gerade schon sehe da ist eine bunte kann
ohne dich grad in der hand halte und das
ist die neuen pkw ohne dass sie ist der
tmp tmp launcher und das jetzt ganz
normale trail mix ist das ganze möglich
machen und das sagt auch schon der name
ist die thermik modifikation habe ich
dass er zwei mal gesagt ich weiß es
nicht es sind so kleine sachen die
trusted ihr euch in dem ihr zucker
schwarzpulver redstone und los von stop
irgendwie im quadrat
zusammen decken crafting banjo denn euer
inventar dann bekommt ihr training ist
natürlich nicht in 16 01 und das könnt
ihr dann einfach zu essen in dem im
gaylord 0 seit und dann seht ihr schon
ein ganzer bildschirm wird ein bisschen
sepia farbener und das ganze hält mit 16
sekunden lang an kann davon natürlich
mehr essen und ich werde die ganze zeit
schneller wenn die sprinter wie ich da
natürlich sehr schnell also einen sprint
verstärkung auf das springen hat das
keinen einfluss aber es ist also eine
art wieder nie so krank halt und was
auch passiert wenn ich jetzt mal einfach
hier wen schlage dann kommen da so
komisch wie zum beispiel kommt dass ein
stück fleisch oder wenn ich den steiger
kommt auch crash aber wenn ich hier
schlage kommt oder squash oder kommt
beim und teilweise sterben die leute auf
direkt nach einem hit bzw 9 auf 2
das ist immer relativ unterschiedlich so
der hier
naja egal hier wird auf jeden fall dass
das so eine art berauschende wirkung hat
und ihr könnt das auch auf ein schwein
machen also auf ein schwein einfach
rechts aufmachen dann blockiert das so
komisch fliegt dann auch so weg und
fliegt danach irgendwo rein und begeht
sri syed wie man so schön auf englisch
dann wird also selbstmord auf deutsch
kann ich euch jetzt nochmal zeigen also
wirklich komische koppeln ausmarsch
fliegt dann gleich irgendwie weg wenn er
nicht so bedrückt das video und fliegt
dann irgendwo rein das wird genau jetzt
passieren nie und ist dann hält tod also
man kann die quasi ein bisschen
aufpassen und ja aber das ist nicht das
einzige was hinzugefügt wird
und zwar noch einen tmp lounger der wird
sich zeigen
rosa farbstoff dorthin dorthin obsidian
dort in einen kolben und dort in ein
spender dann außen so dazwischen
eisenwaren und den mietern schwarzburger
dann bekommt er in themen pp lounge und
es gibt noch einen neuen kleinen ein pkw
ohne kleben wenn ich das ganz gerne
da müsst ihr oben rosen rot orange und
gelb und unten violett hellblau und
hellgrün und in die mit diamanten tpt
mpp lounge und eine glasscheibe ist
erstmal diesen tmp launcher hinkriegen
und dann noch ein diamanten endlich
design pixar aber der hat auch in sich
und zwar was erstmal noch mit diesem
trailer mix machen könnt dafür gehe ich
mal ganz kurzen games ist wenn ihr ein
sattel habt ihr es glaube ich ja genau
ich gehe mal ganz kurz alien das brauch
ich ja alles gar nicht mehr richtig wenn
überhaupt nur weg hier
so ersetzen sattel hier drauf und setz
mich dann auf dieses schwein drauf und
bin dann ein stilmix dann kann ich
dieses ding steuern vermisst das weiß
natürlich wird also dann könnt ihr
dieses ding steuern und zwar die
steuerung ist wenn ihr seht rück geht
hier nach unten mit dem schwein wenn es
dort geht ihr nach oben und ihr könnt
ihn halt immer noch mehr trail mix geben
während der während die da drauf sitzt
es gibt ihn jetzt 1 drückt jetzt es dann
bin ich halt nach oben so ich mach das
mal einen cert person so dann lege ich
es ein bisschen und ihr seht ihr unten
links den countdown 24 steht da gerade
war ich bleib mal ungefähr auf der höhe
24 steht da wo mein kopf ist komisch 24
steht da kann ich einfach noch mit
tricks drauf machen werde dass das ding
so boa
ich komme mit der steuerung
durcheinander dann seht ihr dass der
teil einer hochgeht ich kann jetzt
einfach space drücken im moment momenten
wenn space dann macht er hier so eine
krasse drehung macht er dann kann
einfach so drehen und so dauert das dann
halt ein bisschen länger bei space geht
das ganze ein bisschen schneller da
zählt ihr auch schon so ich möchte mal
ein bisschen darunter bitte so wenn ihr
einfach sterben wollte einfach mein
schwein backen riecht ein bisschen tue
man schweinebacke bisschen herum und er
kann doch einfach kontrolle drücken
jetzt schon so viel zu schwer zu steuern
das kriegen wir hin mit kontrolle jetzt
kontrolle ist halt dass wir einfach noch
ein bisschen schneller sein
also bei schiff seite schnell dabei
kontroll seite langsamer da seht ihr
jetzt bin ich relativ langsam jetzt bin
ich zum durchschnitts mäßig und jetzt
bin ich sehr schnell so wenn ihr das
ganze umbringen wollt dann geht ihr dann
einfach im boden das versuche ich das
war ganz schön hoppelte nicht direkt
davor ihr seht was dann passiert so das
war es jetzt erstmal mit diesem
komischen schwein als ich hasse diese
steuerung davon also man kann dann auch
auf den schweinen so komisch bereiten
ich sortiere nochmal ganz elementar ihr
seht schon ich habe schon vorher so ein
bisschen rumprobieren ist nicht ganz so
toll gelaufen
aber nun kommt zu den einzig geilen
sachen die ich euch ja schon gezeigt wie
man sich die sachen crafted hier und
zwar ein tmp launcher geht nämlich dazu
ja okay ich bin dem creative da kann man
das jetzt natürlich schlecht zeigen aber
wenn ihr rechts gedrückt haltet dann
glaubt diese schweine ein so ich bin es
natürlich schon folglich im creative
mode bin aber die kleinen schweine kann
man zum beispiel nicht an den saugen und
dann habt ihr die halt hier drin wenn
jetzt links klick macht dann schleudert
er dir einfach raus ja das war so ein
scheiß beispiel der bakterien - am boden
rum
für die am morgen aber ich kann dir als
weg schießen und dann fliegen die auch
teilweise einfach so rum jahr deckte zum
beispiel punkt bringt sie jetzt um und
der bringt einfach so rum und ja also
dann kann ich dann wieder mit
rechtsklick auf das schweinchen 35
machen so dann sage ich dir 1 8 bill
greatest agiert die ganze zeit also wenn
ich in game ort wartet sich immer ganz
groß er ein
ich habe angst dass ich sterbe game mode
kann ich hier dann wenn ich jetzt
duschwanne weg schleuder dagegen die
halt runter so jetzt habe ich gar keinen
märz habe ich also keine ambac kann ich
ihm da recht gedrückt halten und sich
jeder neue schöne aufbau dieser wieder
weg und ja das ganze ist dann der tmp
launcher der geht dann oft zu grunde
also ihr seht da unten das eine
haltbarkeit fata und ja kommen nun zum
neuen pick lounge oder sale beim game
und 1 war ich nicht so viel kaputt
machen und ihr kennt alle nyan cat den
song und ja es musste ja so kommen
okay das waren relativ kurz lebenden ein
cat aber er sieht schon und zwar wenn
man davon eine werkstatt dann hörte ich
ein ganz gutes lead-in minecraft wir so
natürlich mit mode blogs und es ist
einen neuen kick also in pick vorn okay
ist auch tot
ihr könnt dann natürlich wie vorhin auch
mit der kanone einfach momente tolle
mode game not 080 so schnell ich noch
ein paar weg
oh mein gott war kaka 76 gleich alles
okay doch nicht also ihr seht ihr haben
der größe explosion des normalen ich
kann jetzt wieder ein paar aufsaugen
so game mode 14 mal wieder eins auf da
habe ich mir ein bisschen wasser und
jetzt haben wir das nicht machen
und tod na ja also das war der neuen
lounge damit könnte auch ein bisschen
spaß haben
das sind erstmals die grund features der
modifikation was sich noch nicht
probiert habe ist dass man ryan kevins
auf dem boden sitzen sattel geben kann
das geht allerdings auch nicht also in
dem video sieht mir und interviews und
in dem text stand das nicht dass das
funktion ich hab's noch nicht selber
getestet
ich denke nicht nur einbringen was geht
das so aus versehen habe falsche taste
gedrückt
außer den screenshot gemacht na ja also
das ist sind so ein paar features ich
kann es noch mal ganz schnell ihr
wolltet ihr immer das nicht so spaß
sachen mache die bei der explosion dass
wir auf einmal den kompletten ozean
explodieren lassen kann ich jetzt mal
einfach so ein paar neuen cat bauen
lassen bis man in minecraft abstürzt
habe ich auch ein paar videos gesehen
aber ich würde erstmal sagen jetzt euch
gefallen hat dann will ich mich über
einen daumen hoch freuen
da zeigt mir das gefallen und da hinten
islam und dass eventuell der mod reviews
haben wollt dann könnt ihr außerdem in
die kommentare schreiben welche
modifikation ich als nächstes vorstellen
soll also welche gerne wünschenswert
findet die völlig bisher sehr geil wurde
mir von euch vorgeschlagen und jetzt
sehr was ihr haltet
das setting noch gar nicht so viel
ich dachte das ist jetzt ab
als ich drücke gerade wie wild auf
meiner linken maustaste rum
der letzte überlebende du schaffst hey
problem dass man hier mit hiermit glaub
ich schneller auch werwolf wir brauchen
schweine
wir brauchen irgendwann daraus gewachsen
ist wenn ausgewachsene schweine
da gibt es tatsächlich keine
ausgewachsene schweine mehr macht hat ja
alles nur damit ihren spaß ab
damit geht das auch alles abwickeln
also
ich hatte ja nie gedacht hat mein pc das
alles aushält aber das ist ja gerade bei
cross also zum thema ich hätte nie
gedacht dass mein pc das aushält gut
mike rodgers abgeschmiert
den druck hat aufgehört zu spielen
zitiert das sehr schön bei minecraft
rage dass er traurig na ja auch meine
lieben freunde wirklich sagen wie gesagt
wenn ceo h noch komische sounds was euch
gefallen hat dürfte eine positive
bewertung abgeben mit den vermissten mal